grayson hit two of six against san
antonio on wednesday night grizzlies
built an early 10-point lead but
second quarter did not go their way and
young counters on the other end with a
floater
the hawks took the lead trey young's
three
front [ __ ] and picked up by anderson
great pass to marat
and the finish from grayson allen
nine straight by the grizzlies five and
26 for the first
and the grizzlies up eight has been an
issue for the grizzlies it was an issue
last year
trey young straight line drive and a
finish
for trae young and he's over three from
three
marantz got an open look at a three
bango john
moran first three-point make of the game
for him
this is what moran does such a great job
of snakes the pick-and-roll which mean
he comes around and then goes back
the other way so his initial defender
can't get to him he's got 11. he's the
game-high scorer john moran in just 10
minutes
trey young gets around gorgie jang
drives finger rolls it up and in
trey young now in double digits with 10.
and then
you keep going and then then i can act
like oh and then i can say the answer
but you just stumped me all the way and
then you called me out
trey young hits his first three of the
game
short rim even the the putback was a
short shot in that instance christie's
have missed their last seven
herter has not missed at all he is seven
for seven six percent
and they've outscored the grizzlies 40
to 28 in the paint
tonight making a very positive
impression
pretty much echoes that sentiment said
he's a special talent great guy off the
court
just one of those next generation game
guys
as he gets a nice lob there to brandon
clark he said both of us are just trying
to show that we can play with the top
players in the league
with his help trae young tend to shoot
valentine's has him on a switch yes
and a foul on valencianas
he put he went into his full bag of
tricks here couldn't get by
shoots that jump shot and you see
marantz nifty footwork against collins
spin scoops
and scores 113 110.
trae young steps through scoops and
scores that's why he's one of the best
clutch scorers in the nba let me see
here
he does that little between the legs he
gets forces valencianas away from the
basket dylan brooks runs young with a
game high 32
marant with 28 they face off on the bear
head logo
young got all the way inside again and
the grizzlies call for time
as they are down eight to the free-throw
line or being able to
have the handles to be able to find easy
shots
in the painted area he has been
fantastic for this atlanta hall